Một lực lượng bú trang về nơi rơi ra thùng báo, tiếng hành chính xe quan sự quy mối lớn trên toàn Quốc.
Theo bụng có phòng nước này, các lượng hành lục không quan tên lửa và sân quan,
cú vực lượng cạnh xa và sân sự đã được quy đọc để tăng gửa khả năng phòng về cho mùi cơ tự bên ngoài.
Đà trên những cuối xa về nơi rơi ra vệ tự về phát hiện ngành mình sẽ ý và hi tại dí chuyển tại như bang cho thấy quy mô chính xe trên cả nước.
Tổng thống Nicolas Maduro Hành định, vên như giữa là sẵn sản từ vệ và sẽ huy động toàn sân nếu sảy sả tấn công,
sống vẫn nhận mạnh mong muốn duy trì hoa bình.
Cung ngày Mỹ sắc nhận đã điều tổ sân bài USJ,
a phó tới khu vực mi là tình trong hôn cầu trên dịch trong ngôn mà tuy,
sự suyện của tổ sân bài này khiến căn thẳng giữa thá lo khá sở vào Washington tự tụp giả tăng,
làm dây lên lông ngày đứng quyết cơ đối đào chú khu vực cari bệ.